this is the essence of functional
programming i'm richard feldman
so we're here at functional conf 2022
this is uh from the website and as
narash mentioned there are a lot of
different programming languages
represented here um these are some of
the icons that were on the website
there's even more than this but just in
case you're not familiar with all the
logos this is apl closure c plus plus
elixir f sharp o camel haskell elm
prologue scala and java and like he said
there's even more at the conference
now you're going to get a different
experience doing functional programming
in each of these languages some
languages have more or different
facilities for functional programming
than others
and of course these different
experiences are going to lead to
different expectations like for example
if you're used to doing functional
programming in haskell and you try doing
functional programming in c plus plus
that's just going to be a very different
experience they're just very different
languages
likewise if you use elixir versus prolog
very different experiences even
programming languages that are sort of
dedicated functional programming
language they're not multi-paradigm at
all they're just functional programming
like closure and elm very different
experiences
and these different experiences will
lead to different expectations which
sometimes doesn't necessarily lead to a
good experience so let me give you an
example of this um so as naresh
mentioned i've been working on this
programming language called rock for the
past couple years um it is a purely
functional programming language but
because performance is a big focus of
the language and not just in terms of
like runtime performance but also in
terms of compile time performance
we've been building the compiler for
rock in rust
and really the reason for this is that
we want to go fast rust is a systems
level programming language gives you a
ton of control over stuff it's not
really known as a functional programming
language per se it's definitely like
imperative at its core but there are a
ton of articles about how to do
functional programming and rust like
tons and tons and tons of them lots of
people talking about here's like a you
know a blog post on how to do functional
programming and rust a video on how to
do functional programming rust there's
even a book on how to do functional
programming and rust so there's lots of
people talking about how to do this and
sort of uh advocating for it
so um because i was writing this
compiler in russ um this is actually my
first time using rust for a serious
project and uh i was much more familiar
with functional programming i've been
doing it for like 10 years
and so i decided i'm going to write the
parser using parser combinators so
that's what i'm familiar with and since
i've heard about all this like
functional programming and rust stuff um
i found this blog post uh from
bottlesoca who is awesome she wrote a
great post about how to do parser
combinators and rust which i actually
used to make the initial parser for this
programming language
and everything was going okay until i
hit a problem um and this commit message
uh actually
this is exactly september 1st 2019 was
when i ran into this problem and the
commit message says attempt at making a
type annotation parser so at this point
i'd gotten to the form i could parse
like expressions and functions and all
these different things i was like okay
let's get to type annotations because
rock's a type check language it has type
annotations
and i got this weird error from the rust
compiler which said recursion limit
reached
basically what it said is you're doing
too much higher order function stuff and
i wasn't built for that so i give up um
just stop doing that
uh i have never seen this happen in any
programming language any compiler i've
ever used except for this experience i
had in rus and needless to say i was
like well i i thought i could do all
this functional programming in ross what
do you mean recursion limit
so kind of my my first takeaway here was
this is this is just
not a good experience
clearly rust is not designed for heavy
use of higher order functions like this
i mean when you look at these like rust
and functional programming and rust
posts a lot of them just kind of talk
about really basic examples like we're
doing a map over an array or a vector or
something like that um but you never
really get into like what if you have a
ton of higher order functions like
parser combinators that's just built in
this giant stack of them um
russ technically didn't do that to a
point but there comes a point apparently
where you just reach the compiler's
limit it's like no just don't do this
anymore
so that was my first take away my second
takeaway was honestly i'm just not
having a great experience trying to do
what to me feels like a normal
functional programming thing in rust
and yet there's all these other people
who have a different experience or are
promoting a different idea of like yeah
you should do functional programming for
us that's a good idea you know rust
heart lambda um all these things and so
this this sort of is an example of us
sort of talking past each other like i
have in my head based on my experiences
an idea of what functional programming
is
but somebody else who's maybe talking
about functional programming rust they
might have a totally different idea of
what functional programming is that
maybe doesn't involve price or
combinators or anything like it
so this is where these sort of different
experiences that we have from doing
functional programming in different
languages can lead to different
expectations and maybe talking past each
other and miscommunications like this i
kind of wish in retrospect that i didn't
have this idea in my head that russ was
a functional programming language or was
the language where it's a good idea to
do functional programming because based
on my idea of functional programming i
was like you know what um i kind of wish
that
i hadn't had that idea i'd just embrace
the imperative aspect of russ because i
think it's quite nice for using doing
comparative programming and rust
but with my elm background this this did
not set me up for success
so in this talk i want to explore though
like what is the common ground between
all these like we're at functional conf
these are lots of different languages
but we're all talking about similar
kinds of ideas
and what i want to try and do is explore
this idea of like what's the essence of
functional programming what's the
minimal
sort of essential
like irremovable part that at that point
we are doing functional programming no
matter what language we're doing it
i'm going to explore this in sort of
three angles first i want to talk about
what are the minimal language features
required to do functional programming
second i want to talk about the
relationship between functional
programming and math because a common
thing that i hear people talk about is
that functional programming is about
math or has a lot to do with math so
what is that relationship
and third what is the functional
programming style like regardless of
what language you're doing it in what is
the actual fp style
okay so let's start about the start with
the minimal language requirements in
terms of features
so a common answer to this question that
i hear in terms of like what is the
actual minimal thing that you need to do
functional programming is lexical
closures
now this is uh an example of a first
class function as a lexical closure but
you might not be familiar with exactly
what that term means so let me go into
sort of an example of what it is
so here we have an inner class in java
this is an example that comes out of a
blog post when they were announcing
lambdas being introduced in java 8. and
in this blog post this is on oracle.com
it says although possible functional
programming in java was by any account
obtuse and awkward
and what they're talking about is
basically code like this
where you're using this inner class in
order to define something that with the
lambda syntax could be defined like this
much more concisely
now worth noting that semantically these
two actually do the same thing in java
like the inner class even can do the
closure thing where it captures stuff
from the outer scope
basically the difference here is is
largely syntactic sugar
like you could like like the quote says
it was possible to do functional
programming in java using this style of
like instantiating a new runnable and
making a method called run inside of it
but it wasn't very pleasant um it
required a lot more code than certainly
the uh the lambda syntax sugar ended up
um
requiring
so
fp in java has always been possible but
it hasn't always been ergonomic and now
with the introduction of the lambda
syntax it's more ergonomic
let me give you another example of uh of
where fp is possible but not necessarily
ergonomic this time using a sort of
different definition of a lambda a
different style of closure i'm going to
use sort of javascript syntax for this
just for familiarity because i think
most people know javascript
let's say i say suffix equals
exclamation point and then i write a
function called exclaim which takes a
string and all it does is it returns
that string plus that suffix of
exclamation point
so in javascript this this function
would work the way you expect if you
call exclaim passing a string it'll
return it with an exclamation point on
the end
but now let's say that when i was
calling that
this exclaim function i just happened to
also put suffix like ahead of that in
the same scope
um let's pretend that we have like a var
or a const or something like that or a
let in front of both of these suffixes
so this is not about global variables
this is let's assume locally scoped
and then i call exclaim in the same way
so in a language with uh
lexical scope lexical closures
this will return hello world with a
question mark even though in the second
example we said suffix equals question
marks if that had a letter or a
construct bar or something like that in
front of it
it would be locally scoped and it would
not affect this you know exclaim
function
but
there's another style of closure where
it would not do that where it would
actually use the suffix that's closer to
the call site rather than the one that
was close to the definition site
and the difference between these is that
the hello world the exclamation point is
lexical scoping where what matters is
what was sort of lexically that is to
say in the source code around it
and then the other style is dynamic
binding which is basically it's it's all
about what was in scope around the call
site
so this exclaim function is actually
going to evaluate suffix from the call
site or what's near the call site rather
than definition site like we might
expect
so both of these work but one of them is
a lot more ergonomic than the other
there's a reason that basically every
language does lexical binding these days
but you might be surprised to hear about
a particular programming language that
used to do dynamic binding so this is a
talk by david turner who is the creator
of the miranda programming language
which is the basically the immediate
presenter to haskell it's like one of
the earliest languages to do lazy
functional programming um
and he talks all sorts of about all
sorts of history it's a really nice talk
i definitely recommend watching the
whole thing um but one of the slides
that he focuses on is he talks about
some myths about lists
pure lisp never existed it had
assignment and go-to that is to say
mutation and like literally go to like
jumping uh to an arbitrary point in the
source code before it had conditional
expressions and recursion as far as i
know lisp was actually this is from 1958
was the original language that
introduced conditional expressions like
if then else that actually evaluates to
a value
and the first language to introduce
recursion
um
he goes on to say lisp was not based on
the lambda calculus
despite using the word lambda to denote
functions it was instead based on first
order recursion equation which is uh
from the mathematician claiming
so basically he's saying that you know
although we talk about lambda calculus a
lot we're going to talk about it some
more later on the talk um
lisp itself was not actually based on it
and in fact the creator of lisp although
he had heard of lambda calculus and knew
about the term lambdas from it he
actually had not really studied it and
he did not base lisp on it
um the m language which was part of lisp
was was first order but you could pass a
function as a parameter by quotation i.e
is the s expression for its code
basically what he's saying right here is
that list original list
did not have higher order functions in
the sense that we typically associate
them with today what you could do if you
wanted was you could basically take the
source code
of that function like a string and pass
it in and eval that
which you know if you've ever heard of
eval language like javascript or
something like that probably alarm bells
are going off like that's not a good
idea that's not a good way to do higher
order functions or to simulate them but
that was what you would have to do in
original lisp and then he goes on to say
this gives the wrong binding rules for
free variables dynamic instead of
lexicographic so that's where our
example previously of dynamic binding
comes from if you imagine if you're just
basically copy pasting that code in
there and then evaling it yeah it's
going to run using whatever's in scope
from wherever you copy pasted it because
it doesn't know about what was
originally in scope all it knows is the
string of the source code that's where
dynamic binding comes from and yeah the
ergonomics are not as nice as lexical
binding
he then goes on to sort of give an
example of this and then finally he
notes not until scheme which is in 1975
uh did versions of lists with static
binding aka lexical binding appear and
today all versions of lists are lambda
calculus based
so this is really interesting because
we've been talking about this sort of
like you know functional programming
being possible but not ergonomic i would
argue that dynamic binding is another
good example of this like yeah we had
lambdas they were even called lambda
isn't this but the ergonomics back in
1958 we're not great they're really not
what we would associate with like
functional programming today with higher
order functions if you said here's a
programming language and the way you do
higher order functions is you pass a
string of the source code into it and
then eval that in the middle of the
function
i don't know how many people would say
yeah that feels like functional
programming to me
now here's the question what's the
difference between this unergonomic way
of doing functions in lisp in 1958 and
this other unergonomic way of doing
functional programming in java in 1995.
i mean both of them yeah you can write
the same kind of stuff i mean arguably
the java one java inner classes did
actually have lexical binding
so in some sense you could even argue
that the java version of this was more
ergonomic for functional programming
despite being more verbose than the lisp
version because at least it got the
binding right
something to think about
okay
this is this is kind of the strangest
part to me is to realize that both java
and lisp
got lexical closures
15 plus years after the initial release
of the language
like people give java a lot of hash for
you know having taken so long to finally
get lambdas i mean lisp took that long
together with us i mean not not exactly
the same amount of time but like 15 plus
years after the initial release before
they got it before a scheme came out in
lisbon before lambdas landed in java 8.
so
school closures are definitely ergonomic
for functional programming but they're
not required you can do functional
programming without it you certainly
could do functional programming in
original lists i think a lot of people
would agree with that some people
including wikipedia as we'll see later
consider lists to maybe be the first
functional programming language ever but
they're not essential they're not
required you can do it without them it's
just the ergonomics are going to be
worse
and honestly the same thing is true of
first class functions i mean we saw from
the inner class example in java that was
not a function that was an inner class
that had a method inside it was not a
function and yet you could do functional
programming in java before it got
lambdas just ergonomics were not as good
and in fact you can go even further with
this you can do functional programming
in c
this is an article about and this is not
just somebody who is doing like a toy
project and was like i want to see if i
can do functional programming and see no
he was actually talking about
i had a real problem and i used my
experience in functional programming to
solve this problem and help make my code
better in c and you can go even further
than that here's a stack overflow
talking about functional code in
assembly like pure functions in assembly
language and that's even more bizarre
because if you think about it assembly
doesn't even have a concept of functions
it's just machine instructions so like
how can this possibly be
well again i come back to
do you actually need
literal first class functions to do a
functional programming style i mean if
inner classes are sufficient in java
what's the difference between that and a
raw function pointer i mean the answer
is there's no capture but again lisp
didn't really have capture so do you
necessarily need that
i think the answer is no i think even if
you don't have the most basic thing the
word function is the first word in
functional programming but you actually
can do that style
of trying to write pure quote unquote
functions
even if you don't have that as a
primitive if all you've got is a raw
function pointer which is just an
address to jump to in memory
it still can help you out in the same
way that the functional programming
style can help you out in java
pre-lambdas and in original list
so yeah i would say even functions are
ergonomic functional programming but
still not required they're not essential
conceptually yeah conception you have an
idea of functions but are they required
to be in the language for you to do a
functional programming style i think the
answer is no
okay so what are the minimal language
features required to do fp i think it's
none not even functions
any programming language can do
functional programming i claim
and if that's true then certainly none
of these other programming language
features are required either to do
functional programming like immutability
not required pattern matching not
required macros i mean all these things
purity laziness these are all things
that are somewhat associated with
functional programming languages and you
might say that these sort of feel like
functional programming if that's what
you're used to
but if you used a programming language
that didn't have any of these
and not even functions i claim you could
still do functional programming at least
from a stylistic perspective and get the
same kinds of benefits that the c
programmer got when he applied
functional programming techniques to his
c code
how granted they do certainly improve
ergonomics uh when you have access to
nice language features i'm making a pure
functional programming language because
i think that that having a language
level support for uh functional
programming is a great idea but i have
to acknowledge that even as someone
who's that committed to functional
programming languages who's been using
them exclusively my career for the past
five plus years um they're not required
for functional programming
okay
so having said that i would encourage
you to explore the different ergonomics
of different languages like if you've
only ever done functional programming in
one or maybe two of these languages try
another one see what it feels like you
might actually find that you like it
more especially if you've never had the
experience of using a language that was
designed from the ground up to be a
functional programming language um the
ergonomics are pretty much across the
board going to be better if you're using
a language where this was the idea this
was the plan rather than a language that
sort of much later ended up deciding
that oh we should actually add some
functional programming language features
even though that's not what the language
was originally designed to do
okay
so that brings me to what is the
relationship between functional
programming and mathematics so this is
another thing that people talk about a
lot
i ended up learning a lot about this uh
when i was trying to answer the question
what's the original definition of
functional programming i wanted to just
say like okay surely
there was a time when no one used the
term functional programming and then at
some point somebody used it for the
first time and then now today it's sort
of part of our shared lexicon so what
was that first moment like what's the
earliest
documented example i can find of someone
using the words functional programming
so i thought it might be alonzo church
who created the laminate calculus back
in the 1930s because a lot of times when
people talk about functional programming
they'll sort of hand-wave you say you
know functional programming originated
with the lambda calculus
um and if you look on wikipedia talking
about the lambda character it says it
influenced the design of the list
programming language yeah not really
true
uh it includes the design of like later
lists not the original list
and functional programming languages in
general which i certainly think is true
but did alonso church in the 1930s
actually use the words functional
programming
i cannot find any evidence of this um i
look through some of his early papers i
don't see that in there
i think that came later even if flame to
calculus was obviously very influential
in functional programming i don't think
it was
the where the term originated
um next place i looked uh was john
mccarthy creator of lisp in the 1950s so
about 20 issue years later
wikipedia says lisp implemented in 1958
was the first dynamically typed
functional programming language
i think that's a reasonable claim i'm
not going to try and debate like was it
or was it not the first functional
programming language some people say it
is some people will say it isn't um
it is weird i i think if you want to be
consistent though you should say that
functional programming does not require
electrical closures if you think that or
being based on the lambda calculus if
you think lisp is the first functional
programming language but regardless did
john mccarthy use the term functional
programming
again i can't find any evidence of this
um i have not seen it in his early like
1950s papers about you know lisp and
symbolic execution all that stuff um
can't find it
the first example i can find of the
words functional programming being used
in a paper
was by peter landon who created lexical
closures uh in the 1960s he wrote a
paper uh that used this term
um he's a british computer scientist one
of the first to realize that lambda
calculus can be used to model a
programming language um definitely has
strongly influenced by lambda calculus
as we will see
um
as far as i can tell he was the first
person to write down the the term
functional programming in like an
academic paper
um it was this one it was called the
next 700 programming languages and it's
from 1966
um we can already see in this paper like
a lot of things that are familiar to us
today in terms of functional programming
he's describing a language which we'll
get to in a second
talks about you know it's oriented
around expressions rather than
statements does that sound familiar um a
non-procedural aka purely functional
subsystem of this language so he's
actually talking about not just
functional programming but like pure
functional programming with no side
effects as part of this language
um
this is where he he talks about
functional programming um he uses the
phrase for the first time functional
programming in a sentence in which he's
actually talking about syntax which i
thought was kind of funny
has little to do with functional
notation
um he goes on to talk about uh he
references another paper he talks about
a correspondence between x and church's
lambda notation basically talking about
like the relationship between lambda
calculus and mathematics and similar
concepts in uh computer programming
the name for his language that that he's
describing here is called i swim which
is short for i see what i mean which i
also thought was kind of funny because
here i am trying to find the original
authoritative definition of functional
programming and all i get is
this sentence which doesn't define it it
just sort of uses it and then it's in
the context of a programming language
called yeah let's see what i mean see
what i mean yeah uh
and so um unfortunately i i did not end
up finding an authoritative definition
here i just found this this usage of it
where he just kind of casually drops it
in there as if the the reader already
knows what it means
so my conclusion is like what's the
original definition of functional
programming
maybe there isn't one it just kind of
seems like this colloquialism that
people were talking about at the time
that like peter landon knew and at some
point he wrote this paper and used this
term that people were colloquially using
and you know what i bet they all
probably had different ideas about
exactly what it meant
so maybe it's always been this way maybe
functional programming has always been
this sort of vaguely shared
understanding of related ideas between
programmers i think that's the most
plausible answer
so to sum up what i ended up sort of
learning in the context
in the course of exploring the the
origins of the term functional
programming
first of all it definitely referred to
mathematical functions like the
functional and functional programming
like all these papers from around this
time they're all talking about math
lambda calculus mathematical properties
and wanting programming to try and sort
of like get some of those benefits from
mathematics or steal some ideas from
there
so definitely that's where the function
uh the word function comes from is
mathematical functions
um
secondly um i learned you know like lisp
is actually not coming from uh a lambda
calculus background but it is coming
from clint's ideas on functional uh
recursion as in mathematical function
recursion um so even more math influence
on the whole like list branch of things
and then i swim and which influence ml
and haskell and all these other
languages um definitely inspired by
lambda calculus and then eventually
lambda calculus ended up getting into
the list family through scheme and uh
and on and on it goes so definitely
there is a very very strong
undercurrent of mathematics sort of like
that's bound up in the origin story of
functional programming
so what about category theory i mean
quite often i've heard people say if you
want to get into functional programming
you're going to have to learn some
category theory is that true
well um so in python uh you have a
concept of lists like a you know another
language that's called an array but
python they're known as lists um and
when python programmers are talking
about lists they say
lists
um haskell also has lists but it's quite
common that you'll hear haskell
programmers talk about the list monad
instead
it's the same idea they're both talking
about lists you know a data structure
called list in their respective
languages um the difference is that you
know colloquially haskell is referred to
as the list monad now in both languages
like python lists and hassellis are both
monads it's like that's just a true fact
about them it's really just there's a
cultural difference about how they're
talked about now part of this granted is
that haskell has monad as part of its
standard library it's really difficult
to use haskell completely without
learning what a monad is it's very easy
to learn python without whatever that is
even though both of them have monads
so um is that required well no i mean an
elm for example which is also a pure
functional programming language like
haskell um statically typed type
inference a lot of similarities between
element haskell but culturally and elm
we just call it lists um that's totally
fine uh similarly in the rock
programming language that i'm working on
so just called lists um you know monads
don't appear in the standard library
there aren't really any category theory
terms it's just a cultural thing and
actually like if you look at the the
breadth of functional programming
whether people are doing like the
functional programming style or it's
just a functional programming language
that's not haskell or a descendant of
haskell you really actually don't find
that much category theory terminology um
there really is just kind of like a
niche of functional programming that
tends to use that terminology
but again like you can find different
experiences no matter where you look um
there's some overlap between
mathematicians and programmers and some
overlap between category theory
terminology usage and programmers and
mathematicians some people are two of
these three some people are three of
these three but plenty of people are
just one of these three and they're
interested in programming but not math
and not category theory and that's fine
all of those are fine so i would say
based on what i've learned i don't think
that category theory is required for
functional programming um but it's
something that you can learn if you want
to and in fact it's also something you
can learn if you have no interest in
programming at all um they're just kind
of separate and
culturally you may find that it's more
of a thing especially in languages where
category
theory terminology appears in the
standard library like in haskell but
there's plenty of other functional
programming languages that don't have it
so if it's not something you're
interested in learning you don't really
have to
okay
and finally this brings us to the
functional programming style
so
what's the common ground stylistically
between all these languages well so far
from what we've explored it doesn't
actually seem that they all have like
some particular set of features that
they all need to have not even functions
that doesn't seem to be a requirement
also although it seems like math is like
an integral part of the origin story of
functional programming i really can't
find any evidence that math is sort of
like part of the definition of it so
it's not like you need to have any
particular math background or usage of
math in order to do functional
programming in any of these languages
so what's the common ground between them
like what are you going to find is sort
of the common thread i expect uh with
like the talks you're going to see at
this conference
using more pure functions i think that's
really kind of what it comes down to so
pure functions if you're not familiar
with the term um basically have two
rules if you give them the same
arguments they have to return the same
return value no matter what
and
they can't perform any side effects
along the way
i really like my favorite analogy for
pure functions is that pure functions
are basically they're not exactly but
basically lookup tables so for example
let's say we have a function called
string length and if i call it passing
the string hi it returns two if i pass
functional it returns 10 if i pass conf
2022 or returns 9.
this could be implemented this function
could be implemented internally as a
lookup table like whatever string you
give it it's going to just look up the
answer in the lookup table and return it
that's it no side effects and no matter
what arguments you give it it's always
going to return exactly the same answer
so if you wanted to you could take the
body of this function whatever is
actually in there and theoretically you
could return it
replace the entire body of that function
with a gigantic lookup table for like
all the possible strings it could
possibly accept now okay that's like
assuming unlimited system resources
obviously in practice you would not
actually be able to implement it that
way but the idea
is that any pure function
should in theory given unlimited
resources be able to replace its entire
body its entire implementation with a
gigantic lookup table
if you can't do that you don't have a
pure function that's the rule
and really if you think about it
mathematical functions work the same way
mathematical functions don't have side
effects and and certainly if you give
them the same arguments they're expected
to give the same return value every
single time
okay
so actually i mean true functions are in
some sense like mathematical functions
and certainly based on the history we've
learned it seems like that's what people
wanted them to be more like i mean
that's that was sort of the goal is to
get more mathematical properties out of
programming um
but there is one important difference
between pure functions and mathematical
functions which is they can crash
uh system resources as it turns out are
finite so you can get for example a
stack overflow they can also hang like
they can run indefinitely and not
terminate that's also a bummer um so
this is a little bit awkward um and
there's this sort of natural question
that arises from this which is
like
can computers do arbitrary math i mean
can we ever get to pure functions being
equal to mathematical functions
unfortunately the answer is no
um and to prove this to you just here's
a thought experiment let's imagine that
you were thinking of the biggest number
you can conceive of just digits and
digits and digits for ages huge huge
number
now raise that number to the power of
itself over and over and over again
as many times as you can imagine
the resulting number will be so big
that even if you don't do any operations
on it it can be represented in the
universe not just on your computer but
like in the entire if you repurposed
every all the matter in the entire
universe and all you were trying to do
with all the matter in the entire
universe was represent this one number
you can't do it it's too big it won't
fit in the entire universe
math unfortunately is infinite even just
that one number is not representable let
alone any functions that might involve
that number is like a constant inside of
it
so can we ever get to a point where
functions running on a computer are as
powerful as mathematical functions in
other words
can we ever get to a point where there
exists no mathematical functions that
cannot be modeled by computers
unfortunately not i mean computers can
never have true mathematical functions
in the sense that there will always
exist a mathematical function that
cannot be represented by a computer
because math is infinite and the
physical universe is finite and
computers live in the physical universe
unfortunately so we can sort of
asymptotically approach this at best but
we can never quite get there
okay so one of the things that pure
functions can do is they can crash this
is unfortunate but there's also some
other asterisks in there that we just
kind of like hand wave away when we're
talking about pure functions versus
mathematical functions like technically
they affect memory when they run like
they allocate memory on the stack or on
the heap um and we don't really consider
that a side effect even though that
is observable within the system i mean
if you have another you know
another function running that's like not
a pure function it's going to be able to
observe that memory so we kind of like
to say like okay but for our purposes
we're not going to treat that as a side
effect and yes we know they can crash
and they can you know not terminate they
can run out of memory
but all of those all of those aside um
we're just gonna you know otherwise
treat them under the assumption that
those things like won't happen or that
the changing of memory won't matter
um also as we've seen earlier they don't
really even have to be functions i mean
mathematical functions yes or functions
but we can get kind of the same benefits
with much worse ergonomics even if we
don't have access to lexical closures or
something like inner classes in java or
even functions themselves
okay
so putting all this together
i'm going to claim that the functional
programming style basically boils down
to using more pure functions which in
practice
means
avoiding mutation and avoiding side
effects and you can do both of these
even if you don't actually have access
to functions
this i claim is the functional
programming style avoid mutation and
avoid side effects and so what's the
common ground between all these
different things that you'll see at the
conference
i think it's avoiding mutation and
avoiding side effects
so to give an example of this um and
sort of the difference in ergonomics
here
let's talk about like functional
programming in javascript it's actually
what i got into first okay it was
coffeescript but i know a lot not a lot
of people know about coffeescript
anymore so let's just pretend it's
javascript close enough basically the
same language in a lot of ways um and
and comparing that to functional
programming in haskell let me tell you a
quick story um years ago i was working
at a different company and uh we were
basically building a product and the
team that we were on was really bought
into functional programming we were
using coffeescript again pretend it's
javascript um but basically the rules
that we tried to follow were like just
pretend it's haskell like don't do any
mutation don't do any side effects
except at the very edges of the system
um let's try to follow all the same
rules that we would in haskell everybody
was bought into this idea
i had one co-worker who was used to
haskell i was actually used to
coffeescript so i had no prior
experience in doing like functional
programming in an actual functional
language and so to me the ergonomics
were like wow i noticed that it's a lot
easier to do my programming um i find
that this is less error-prone than what
i'm used to but my co-worker really had
a lot of trouble because he was used to
haskell he was like
this is so much harder for me like he
actually ended up leaving the team
because
it was just so impossibly difficult for
him to
give up the ergonomics that he was used
to from haskell and do functional
programming in javascript where it was
just such a much more hostile
environment than he was used to for that
style
now in contrast today i work at a
company called no red ink we make
software for english teachers and we use
elm on the front end and haskell not
exclusively but we do use it quite a bit
on the back end
and basically uh now i know what my
coworker was talking about in the past
um the ergonomics difference is huge if
you have access to all this stuff um
doing the functional programming style
in a language that wasn't designed for
it is very very different ergonomically
and in terms of like what it feels like
day-to-day programming
when you actually have access to a full
language that was designed to be used in
that way
l and haskell are both pure functional
programming languages but again lots of
other languages at this conference um
are you know like elixir and closure and
stuff like that
are dedicated functional programming
languages that are not pure functional
there's lots of different ways to go
with this but the point being if you
actually have a language that's built on
this the ergonomics are very very
different
by the way if that sounds interesting to
you if you'd like to use pure functional
programming language to work we're
hiring
um okay so i claim that avoiding
mutation and side effects is sort of the
uh the common thread between all these
this is the functional programming style
but the ergonomics definitely may vary
depending on the language and its level
of support for that
okay so summarize all the things we
talked about um
building this programming language
called rock it's a purely functional
language compiler is written in rust um
i had this
expectation based on all these things
i'd seen about functional programming
and rust that oh this is going to match
with my idea of functional programming
it's going to feel just like elm but
really it turns out that we were to some
extent talking past each other i mean
all these articles that we're talking
about functional programming and rust
they have a different mental model of
functional programming and especially
the corresponding ergonomics around that
that i did and i ended up kind of
getting burned by that and having an
unpleasant experience when i tried to
apply functional programming techniques
like parser combinators that i was used
to in rust
um so these different experiences you
know can lead to different expectations
and you're going to find a lot of
different uh expectations and
experiences at the different talks that
you hear in the conference and so you
should be aware of that you know what
when the speaker is talking about their
experience of functional programming
it's probably going to be different than
your experience and probably different
than the other speakers experiences you
should keep that in mind as you're
listening to every talk
we talked about so sort of these looking
at this from these three different
angles so what are the minimal features
required to do functional programming as
it turns out none not even functions
it's possible to do a functional
programming style even in assembly
language with terrible ergonomics
what's the relationship between
functional programming and math
definitely there is a very strong
historical influence this seems to me to
be where the term functional programming
came from was people looking into the
relationships between mathematics and
programming and pure functions
themselves are definitely based on
mathematical functions the function in
functional programming comes from
mathematical functions as far as i can
tell
and finally what is the functional
programming style it's avoiding mutation
and avoiding side effects
of course the ergonomics
may vary depending on which language
you're you're doing that styling
so what is at the end of the day the
essence of functional programming i
think it's avoiding mutation and
avoiding side effects
thanks very much